today's draft the biggest whoa moments
from round one of the 2020 Draft let's
go I have a trivia question and I will
find the trivia question it is this the
Chargers Chris took Justin Herbert at
number six overall last night if he
begins the year under center he'll
become just the fourth starting
quarterback for the Chargers since 2001
who were the other three starting
quarterbacks for the Chargers since 2001
Wow okay so Drew Brees and Phillip
Rivers and then man for this one if
you're gonna get in trouble for this one
I'm gonna is there gonna be I mean mine
is this obvious there's a Billy bollock
Billy Volek no it's it's somebody who
work with on Saturdays in the fall oh my
gosh Doug Flutie he got a start he and
starts in there damn dog you damn it
let's get to the draft first one for me
without question when the Packers traded
up to take Jordan love yes the to a
moment was you know earlier in the draft
and it was a stunner because we didn't
know where he was going to go but talked
about pulling the rug out from under oh
Aaron Rodgers the Packers not only draft
Jordan love they trade it up to do it
it's an extra exclamation point on the
middle finger to Aaron Rodgers high
drama in Green Bay that will continue to
resonate well into this offseason and
beyond that was the stunner to me that
was the jaw-dropper Utah State
quarterback Jordan love to the Packers
after trading up to get him with Aaron
Rodgers just one year into his latest
big-money contract yeah I mean the
shocker of shockers you're right and I
don't understand it you know I really
respect you know guti the GM up there in
Green Bay a whole lot but this is one
I'm not so sure I totally agree with and
I'm interested to see how the Green Bay
fans really received this and what their
reaction of this is going forward but
that was the obvious first pick I think
you know I almost don't want to pick it
but Tula is the next obvious pick I mean
that was a low moment we had no idea
what the Dolphins were gonna do we
didn't think they would really take a
chance on tua at number five I did
I think a lot of people in the NFL
thought they would pass and then maybe
try to make a play on him a little later
on in the first round at some point so
you know that was I think the first
surprise moment of the first round where
you know the first four picks were chalk
the first three picks were chalk I think
we all thought the Giants were gonna go
off into tackle we just didn't know
which one the Dolphins picked when I
don't think anybody's had a real feel of
where could it go Herbert - uh well they
pass on the quarterback and go tackle
and wait a little longer so I think that
was the second biggest wall moment
behind your Danube
yeah well and I agree with you that that
was number two behind Jordan loving the
next one from me I'm gonna move on to
the Cowboys having a receiver like CD
lamb slide into their clutches at number
17 I fully suspect he'll be the next guy
to wear number 88 in Dallas in that
tradition from Drew Pearson to Michael
Irvin to Dez Bryant I think they're
gonna dust it off for CD lamb and it's
another weapon for dak it's another
reason to get excited about that offense
as they change from Jason Garrett as the
head coach to Mike McCarthy so that was
a stunner that was a surprise how about
them Cowboys getting a flashy player
from not all that far away in Oklahoma
to come down to Dallas and help get
things done no doubt about it Jerry
loves him some Oklahoma players you know
if you're good and you're from Arkansas
Oklahoma or Texas he's got you on the
radar and that you can count on that and
I'm with you this was amazing that he
was still there at 17 no brainer awesome
picked by the Cowboys alright my next
one I think I'm gonna go with what what
I saw with the top three picks and I
mean this in a low moment the fact that
the top three picks were all on the same
college football team at one point and
that to me it was a WoW moment
I mean Okuda chase young and Joe burrow
we're all walking around the locker room
at Ohio State at the same time the three
picks of the NFL Draft all on the same
college football team I mean we've never
had that now I know bro how to leave and
go to LSU but I can't recall ever the
top three picks being from the same
school at some point so I know it's a
little different here but we're
cordless that's just an amazing feat let
alone you think about all the other
first-round talented guys that have been
in that locker room - over the last few
years at Ohio State yeah I agree with
you completely and it is amazing what
they've amassed there and it's amazing
they don't win the national championship
every single year with the talent that
they have in Columbus Ohio all right the
next one for me we talked about this
earlier but it was a WoW moment
Henry rug's the third even though he
told me earlier this week the Raiders
the Broncos and the 49ers were
constantly contacting him I didn't
expect him to be the first receiver off
the board I didn't expect the Raiders to
take him at number 12 but here that four
to seven forty the Al Davis effect
getting the fast receiver on the field
to try to give Derek Carr a chance to
develop into the quarterback they need
him to be and you know this is their
this is their Antonio Brown didn't work
out we still need a receiver moment and
hopefully rugs can be what they need as
they make the move to Las Vegas Chris
well you know I was gonna pick this too
because the most one thing about the
Henry rugs pick was the dude was wearing
a robe okay he was wearing an old spice
robe that was unreal one of those robes
I have new you really yeah that's
amazing I should have worn it onto the
show today damn it you should have that
would have been really cool but that was
I thought really cool I've got it shows
the player too I mean he's a little
fearless it got a little pizzazz and
personality about him so yeah that was
like a double a double whammy there with
Henry rugs all right I mean you know how
the guy on the toilet it was probably
the next big wall moment for me I mean
when you're sitting there watching TV
and my wife picked it out where she went
wait wait did you see that in the
background what is that and then a few
minutes later it kind of went on Twitter
and I was like oh my gosh Danielle
you're right there was something there
and you know just when you see a guy
sitting on the toilet in the background
during the draft that's a well moment so
sorry Mike variable bringing us the
biggest ball moment you know I don't
know what was the guy going number two
is he sitting down taking you stuff I
don't just
No will you stop between between the
Smurfs man on the left and whatever I
was trying to do on the right
we missed the fact that yeah Jimmy's
Jimmy's in the in the bathroom and his
phone apparently he's that Potter
there's two things you're doing when
you're sitting like that you're either
checking your phone or you're rolling a
joint it's one of the two am i right you
are it looks like a cancer down though
so you don't usually roll join two
different
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports